so come Oh simple butterflies are a
symbol of life and change they're
constantly transforming from an egg to a
larva to a caterpillar a chrysalis and
then the butterfly the butterfly stage
is the shortest in life - it can take
time to fulfill your dreams but it's
worth it then to enjoy the fulfillment
of those dreams after suffering serious
back problems
Geneva cos was no longer able to
continue her office job it was then that
she discovered her love of butterflies
which opened up a new job opportunity
now she works 10 hours a day breeding
the insects she spends a lot of that
time searching the leaves of plants for
butterfly eggs and caterpillars it
allows me to live in harmony with nature
and help protect the environment without
plants and nature there would be
something missing in our lives
this work helps me to relax and gives me
a sense of calm
she breeds ten different species of
butterfly all of which are destined for
export
not long ago Geneva qez and her family
moved to this finca in San Ramon right
near the Costa Rican capital San Jose
she needed more space for the large
number of plants on which her
butterflies depend species of butterfly
lays its eggs on a particular plant
these are known as host plants then they
also need flowers with nectar or pollen
some 400 Costa Rican families now earn
their living as butterfly farmers the
country is home to several thousand
species of butterfly Costa Rica supports
an enormous variety of Wildlife and has
one of the highest levels of
biodiversity in the world
the farmers work with companies that are
specialized in export they send out
butterfly crystallises all over the
world
[Music]
we want to know exactly where the
butterflies are going and what they'll
be used for we can't export them just
for the sake of it we need to know how
they'll be treated
that's the ethical standard we have in
our company and that we pass on to the
other exporters the butterflies are
ambassadors of beauty of the nature of
our country so we have to be sure that
they can fulfill this function at their
intended destinations company I suppose
young this company alone sends out
30,000 crystallises every week they have
70 different species all of which are
transported by air they mainly go to
Botanical Gardens and butterfly
sanctuary in places like the United
States and also Europe and Russia
the company is only able to offer so
many species because it works with
breeders all over Costa Rica most of
them are in areas where there are hardly
any jobs or only jobs that are damaging
to the environment butterfly farming on
the other hand is about protecting the
environment ricardo murió an
entomologist from the University of
Costa Rica aims to promote
environmentally friendly jobs in rural
areas as part of his work he advises
butterfly farmers to breed these insects
you have to protect the forest here we
have two hectares of forest without it
we wouldn't be able to breed butterflies
here so maintaining the right
environment is key butterflies can only
live in an intact ecosystems but this
practice of breeding them commercially
and exporting them all over the world
has critics butterfly farming involves
removing plants from the wild for
example and when transported by plane
the insects are subject to physical
jolts and changes in temperature
well Gio says that's not such a problem
butterflies can't feel pain the insects
don't have the neural receptors to do
that they do sense mechanical impulses
but not pain as we know it their nervous
system is different so it's not cruel he
says it's mainly women who breed the
butterflies women like these four
sisters he also advises butterflies are
their world
they've chosen to specialize in two
particular species the giant owl
butterfly which is as big as the palm of
your hand and the glass winged butterfly
together the sisters earn around $800 a
month that's a good income here in a
rural community where many people have
little school education we wouldn't be
able to find a job otherwise not a
well-paid one anyway but here as long as
we work hard we can earn well and we are
our own boss about 50 years ago Costa
Rica began establishing national parks
and reserves where biodiversity is
specially protected that's allowed
butterfly farming to flourish here and
harmony with nature and help preserve
these amazing insects which embody the
diversity and vulnerability of Costa
Rica's Wildlife
you